Hello, everybody. This is Dr. Kevin Cutters. We're going to be going over our Zoom call to call you good people who have
I did questions. So make sure you chat in question. A lot of them are submitted. So make sure you chat in a question. We're going to have a round.
I always remember to check what's going on with the announcements. And make sure you don't schedule if you so desire.
Alright, let's get to the first question.
Hi, Dr. Cutters. I paid for 10 sessions of photo dynamic therapy last year when no cancer was detected in my body.
Hopefully that photo dynamic therapy would help keep it away. And it didn't. The cancer grew, buried in the photo dynamic therapy treatments.
I have about five sessions left. It's a worth it to finish out the sessions or do you think it's better to ask to use the money towards other services products that the doctor offers.
He sent me links talking about efficacy of photo dynamic therapy, but I don't know if I'm being taken advantage of or not.
I'll send you the links for review. What do you think?
So photo dynamic therapy can be beneficial for different people. Now understand, and I have talked about this more with photo dynamic therapy is photo dynamic therapy is a broad term.
It's kind of like saying I'm doing the right machine.
Um, well, which right machine because you can call anything a right machine and it doesn't necessarily mean it's a machine that's using light frequencies.
It doesn't mean that it's a frequency that has enough amperage to actually penetrate your body.
It doesn't mean that you're using a machine that is programmable to the frequencies of your cancer. So there's a lot of same thing with photo dynamic therapy.
So photo dynamic therapy is basically anything that's using laser falls into that category.
So it really depends on the machine that they're doing.
But even that if let's say if I was doing something and during that process, let's say I was doing chemotherapy and during chemotherapy my cancer grew, then why would I continue the same chemotherapy?
I think that it would be a hint to maybe think about switching up therapies. No, maybe you can argue that I didn't do enough. I didn't do it often enough. I didn't do it.
There's different variables that may need to be addressed, but I would definitely say that, you know, in this case, be it alternative therapy, I would switch to something else personally.
So I would switch to maybe an IV therapy or something like that.
Next question. I started taking fenmen for parasites. I was taking the 10 pound version, one pack per day for four days, then three days off and repeat.
This time I bought the 40 pound version. I'm not sure how I should dose myself now. I weigh 98 from pounds. I'm also on Ivermectin pace. Am I getting it over my head?
Okay, so personally, I wouldn't take fenmen for parasites. Why not? So they take parasitic medication.
Yeah, you're right. It is. I would take, I would take an herbal antiparasite. If I had, if I was thinking I had parasites, I would take an herbal antiparasitic.
So my favorite is the one that we privately able to pair a clear. It's, it's professional health products over the future. It's always been my favorite antiparasitic nutrient, or since I discovered it.
So what's got just a great mix of it and we used it, you know, dozens and dozens and dozens of times for people with parasites.
I used the medication for parasites. It has too many side effects at the dosage that you would have to take.
So personally, I just, I wouldn't do that. So I would never recommend that. And then secondly, from a legal medical legal standpoint, I can't tell you to take a medication for parasites.
I just personally wouldn't do that. I would choose something else.
And, you know, make sure that you've discovered, you know, what it is you're trying to deal with. The reason why I like paraclear is it covers pinworms, tapeworms, roundworms.
It's got the negative about taking paraclear is that you have to kind of titrate up on the dose. Maybe start a three a day. I've had people have to go up to 12, 15 a day. But for a very short period of time.
So that's something you need to take all the time. And usually you're going to go, you're going to keep a bottle in your cupboard. That's what I do. We have a model of it actually two models. I noticed in our cabinet.
And what even if I'm feeling down if I feel like I'm coming down with something, I'll take that.
So it can be beneficial for viruses and bacteria as well. But it's really for intestinal liver, parasites, flukes.
And it really does work well. It works. I've used it on people for even trigonosis that has gone to their head to their brain. And it is cleared it up like super fast.
So it's it's my favorite. I would use the medication. I would use paraclear. The negative is OK. If you're 90, fairly 98 pounds, you'll probably take a maximum of six or nine a day. But you might only take that for a couple days or a week. And then you'll titrate back down to three a day. And then you might go off of it.
Well, I take it for two weeks and just hit it like that for two weeks and then wait a month or so and do it again. If you feel like you still have parasites. That's when I guess.
Next question. COVID seems to be going around again. Have any must have items that we need to keep around.
Well, if, if to be honest, I'm not convinced that COVID could was the cause of everybody's illness last time at quote unquote, wet around.
The test for it is worthless. And if you did the test and a tested positive for you to think that you had COVID, even though the COVID test was positive, your mistaken doesn't mean you don't have it, but you had just as great or probably 80% chance that it was some other virus or some other bacteria that you contracted and were dealing with.
Well, that's a side note. What should you do for viruses or bacteria? Are they created worse viruses in the lab and creating them to be more viral and dangerous to humans, very ill and dangerous to humans? Yes, they are. Why are they doing that? That's really conspiratorial. Well, yeah, it is, but it's true.
So we can get into the conspiracies of why they're doing those kind of things, but that's the truth. Those things are, there's different viruses and different bacteria that we're going to be exposed to that are going to be very ill and could cause issues. That's why you should have that's where I would use Iverbacter.
That's where I might use some medication like that. So keeping that in your cupboard, having that in stock would be a wise thing to do. I think paracleric is another wise thing to have in stock.
Now, there's a company that we sell a lot of their products. I really like their products called professional formulas. They sell a lot of, they're really up on this and they sell a lot of homeopaths for these things.
You can get H1 and one H1 into homeopathics. That's why the homeopaths. So think about having some of those in stock. I mean, the life, the shelf life on those is, you know, really forever. So having to keep you that in your cupboard, because those are going to like so instantly it another
a pandemic takes place. So having those in stock, having your cupboard with some of those things can be beneficial. Now, things like, okay, you know, the stock expectancy, meaning the life expectancy of some nutrients like echinacea can diminish over time. So echinacea, some herbals like that.
You know, have a shelf life of maybe, you know, two, three years, four years. Paracleric because it is not necessarily immune stimulant herbals. It can have a shelf life where the herbals will typically just diminish their potency over time.
So you might have to just take more. Now, other supplements like vitamin C and like our, like our clear CV, like clear CV was created basically for COVID, right.
We call it clear CV for kind of a hidden name for because we can't say COVID, but it's just to be in general immune stimulant zinc, anacetyl cystine, vitamin C, a couple of things in that vitamin A.
So it's just a general immune stimulant if you feel like you have a virus.
So that's a good thing to keep on here. Now, what that has a expiration date on it, like everything legally has to have an expiration date on it, but quite honestly, the expiration date.
It's not the half different antioxidants like an ac in it, it literally nearly expires. So it's, it's going to stay, you know, potent for, you know, a decade or two. So having that once in stock and even in the back of your cupboard is good to have in case something crazy goes on.
But you know, it's probably going to happen in the next several months, something is going to happen. So you just need to be as prepared and wise as possible without being crazy about it or anything like that.
Next question, I agree about the COVID test, etc. But something seems to be attacking everyone I know who
who has traveled on an airplane lately. Yeah, because I think they are creating things. Plus I do think, you know, some
some environments are more prime for issues when you're at a crowded airplane and the doctor work on the airplane is never been cleaned and there's mold and garbage in the doctor.
You're reading all this stuff in, you know, a lot of people will tell me they get sick every time they fly, you don't feel good after they fly, they have to deal with those kind of things plus the radiation that you go through the airport. All this kind of stuff too.
So yeah, so you do want to be prepared with something. So some of those things that I talked about are good things to travel with. Whenever we travel, we always bring it with different homeopaths can be beneficial to help ward off those things to learn things about the opposite as well.
So I think it's always good to be wise, it's always good to be as prepared as possible without being fearful.
So we're not called to be fearful, but we are called to be wise. So there's that balance between being anxious about the future, which is not godly and be wise about the future, which is godly. So you have to strike that balance and that's that's the key.
So to me, from a health care perspective, being wise about the future is just taking precautions.
You know, we try to grow as much of our own food as possible and currently today my project was to can make beans and ever can make beans.
I'm really the can eat really into pressure can eat it. I made jams and jellies and because we grow so much blasted food. Why do we grow so much food? I don't know, we're just crazy because we love the garden of my wife and I are avid gardeners.
And it's an addiction and every year we laugh because we're cutting back this year. Next year we're not going to put in this. We're not going to put in this.
But then they put in this giant, freaky, enormous garden and oh, I have an extra row. So I guess I'll plan to the entire 110 foot row of beans. Well, half of it was beans. The other was care was more onions, which we don't need.
More, you know, jalapeno peppers. So 20 plants of that is crazy. But I don't know if it's an addiction. I need to go to gardeners anonymous or something. Most of my wife and I, but since we planted that we have this obsession about, oh, we don't want to waste it. So I, a couple of years ago, got it's really big and decadied.
And because we used to do it years ago, we can't for, you know, our kids at home, but now we're able to provide food for our adult kids and their families. And that's really a blessing. I like doing that. It's fun. That's become a hobby of ours.
So the benefit of that is we are eating better quality food. We're not eating as much food with chemicals in it. And that's going to keep us healthy. Is it.
Are we doing it out of anxiety and anxiousness? No. But we're, it's, it's, we enjoy doing it now. I know some people don't enjoy doing any of that. So find somebody that doesn't join doing it.
Yes, and for some vegetables. So you just make as many precautions as you can to try to stay as healthy as you can.
As far as the supplements go, the things that I mentioned and some whole you pass against some of these strange viruses that they may be trying to produce can be a good thing to add to your cabinet to stay safe because that's a great thing to help stimulate your immune system again.
Your immune system against these things. And it's wise decision to do to prevent as much diseases you possibly care. Okay. Any other questions?
I don't see an unparac Clear. Well, with the way that you gave me. If you the one that asked that question if you're 98 pounds, I would start at three a day.
And, and then see how you do. I mean, sometimes you don't have to go beyond that. And if you notice that you're flushing a lot of parasites, maybe I just stand at that. You don't notice anything.
a lot of times when you're flushing, you are killing parasites, you're not going to notice anything.
So you won't, I mean, you won't see it in your stools. Everybody can be obsessed with seeing
something in their stools, but you don't always see things in your stools. Things get digested
and broken down, and you don't see a parasite in your stools quite, honestly, quite often.
So, but if you feel like your symptoms are getting better, then maybe that's all you would
stay at, but you feel like you need more than you could just titrate up. So titrating up about
on some supplements can be beneficial. At 98 pounds, I would think going six a day to nine a day
would be the maximum, and then you maybe only do that for a few days to maybe a week, and then you
titrate back down to three a day, and you might do that for another week, and then you might go off.
So personally, I don't take that all the time, but you know, I've mentioned that on this call
that I think we need to treat for parasites on a fairly regular basis. So I do take paraclear.
Like I said, if I just feel like I'm coming down with something, which was just last week,
I couldn't talk. I lost my voice, which many people would cheer, but I took a bunch of paraclear,
and I was, you know, took about two days, and I felt like that was back to the normal.
So yeah, it can be a great thing for other things other than parasites. So
there's a reason why I like it because it's so broad spectrum. There's a lot of 15 different herbs
in there. When I took it, when I wasn't feeling good, I took six at one time, and then I took like five
more before bed. I just wanted to knock it out of me. So, all right. No more questions. Well,
thanks for being on, and we'll see everybody next week. God bless, everybody. Have a wonderful week.
Enjoy the weather. Hopefully your weather's good where you are, and see you next week. Bye-bye.